the daily wire reports Hunter Biden's
former business partner reportedly
confirmed to the house oversight
committee that President Joe Biden was
on more than 20 calls with his son
during a closed door meeting on Monday
Republican members pressed for details
about alleged foreign business dealings
involving the president during his time
in the Obama Administration
Devin Archer who served as the Director
of Ukrainian Energy company barisma
alongside Hunter Biden reportedly
ignored questions from the press as he
walked into the O'Neill house building
yesterday the committee was expected to
interview Archer for approximately five
hours where Republican Democrat members
rotate between our blogs to investigate
the key witness who has alleged Hunter
put then Vice President Joe Biden on
speakerphone roughly two dozen times as
Hunter spoke to his foreign business
partners or investors beginning in 2014.
representative Dan Goldman who was
reportedly the only left-wing politician
president in the room during Archer's
testimony said that Archer quote
indicated that Hunter spoke to his
father every day in approximately 20
times over the course of a 10-year
relationship The Daily Mail reported now
um
so he's reporting
uh over 20 occasions where Joe Biden
again this is Joe Biden while he is Vice
President while he's in the White House
on the phone with Hunter Biden's foreign
business partners and investors
but what were they talking about okay is
a question and Dan Goldman has an answer
for that
and you know it's it's interesting to
hear what he says and also just how he
looks everything you could tell that
he's panicked he's very flustered
um he doesn't know what to say
because he's just come out of this out
of this uh out of this
five hour investigation interrogation
he's heard all of this and he knows that
it's bad
but he's trying to find some kind of way
to let Biden off the hook and this is
what he comes up with listen
so to confirm you're saying that the
speakerphone conversations they don't
seem concerning to you because there is
no specifics about business and it just
seemed like it was clear that it was
clear that it was part of the daily
conversations that Hunter Biden had with
his father
um and it was and and sound is like most
of the time uh
now President Biden didn't even know who
the people he was at dinner he was just
asked to say hello uh and he would you
know talk about the the way he described
it several times they asked over and
over and over he described what the
weather was how uh how what's going on
on your end he the the witness was very
very consistent that none of those
conversations ever had to do with any
business dealings or transactions they
were purely what he called casual
conversation
oh they were just talking about the
weather that's all they were talking
about which uh first of all who like
like Joe Biden would even know the
weather uh like that's that's a
conversation you could even have as if
he's aware enough now this was back in
2014-15
slightly less senile back then
um but you know they're just talking
about the weather that's all nothing to
worry about uh the fact that his his dad
is happens to be vice president it's the
total you know this got nothing to do
with it
hey business partner let me put you on
the phone with my dad who happens to be
vice president just so he could say hi
to you
so we're we are supposed to believe
that Joe Biden at this point was
operating in his capacity simply as a
proud father of his crackhead son and
that the fact that his vice president
had nothing to do with the conversation
well if that's the case why
why would you put like if your dad is
not the vice president
why would you put him on the phone
randomly with your with business
partners or investors who you claim he
doesn't even know
let me call my daddy up so you can talk
to him what when would that ever happen
why would you ever do that
well you would do it if your dad's the
vice president you're trying to use his
influence in your business in your
corrupt business dealings that's the
only reason you would do that right okay
if if Hunter Biden's Dad if Joe Biden
was a plumber well the world would be
the world be a much better place right
now if Joe Biden was a plumber uh now
maybe the houses that he worked on as a
plumber would not be in such great shape
but certainly the world would uh but if
his dad's a plumber or something or
works at uh you know the deli down the
street
if he's the manager of uh of the local
Walmart
does Hunter Biden gonna put his dad on
the phone with his business partners
yeah
that's what we're supposed to believe
now of course
the idea that they didn't talk about
business at all they only talked about
the weather is absurd
but even if it's true which it isn't
it still wouldn't exonerate Joe Biden
because after all this is how influence
pet peddling works it's all about making
the connection so in some ways doesn't
really matter what Joe said on those
calls the fact that he got on the calls
in the first place
as vice president inserting himself into
these business dealings with his son in
in overseas
that's all that matters there's the
corruption it doesn't actually matter
what was said
because the only reason again to get on
the calls is to establish the connection
to use his influence to help his son in
his corrupt business dealings
uh that's that's the whole point
so it might be true that in some of
these conversations the weather they
pretended to make small talk and the
weather came up so what
you don't need to get on the phone Joe
doesn't need to get on the phone and say
uh listen I'm going to use my political
position of vice president United States
and my position power to help you with
this thing and in exchange you'll do
this and like that's not generally how
it works
but um that's if you buy the the whole
they talked about the weather bit which
obviously I don't and you shouldn't so
yes Biden is corrupt the whole family's
corrupt his son's a crackhead and
corrupt and all of that is true
absolutely
okay
and maybe you get tired of hearing me go
on about this but for me it all comes
back to once we've established that and
I think we have established that for any
reasonable person
it all comes back to Republicans and the
same question I'm always asking which is
what are you going to do about it
that's that's the only conversation I'm
interested in having at this point now
some people get upset at me because I
don't spend more time talking about
Biden on the show and his corruption and
all that okay there are there aren't
very many shows of mine that uh the the
lead topic is here's the latest with Joe
Biden here's all the Terrible Things Joe
Biden's doing
um and the reason I don't do that is
well for one thing I don't Focus as much
on politics I focus on culture but also
we all get it right like and the whole
audience gets it
I'm not interested in continually
repeating the Mantra about how Biden is
a criminal if Republicans aren't going
to do anything about it
and they can't really right now
except all they can do right now is
basically symbolic there's there's some
value in symbolic gestures
but will they do something if they have
the power to do so if you love venturing
into the Great Outdoors you know that
staying connected is essential for
safety and peace of mind that's where
satellite phone store comes into play
their devices help you stay in touch
with friends family and Emergency
Services even when you're far from
cellular coverage satellite phone stores
bivy stick and satellite Communicator
use satellite networks for phone calls
text messages GPS navigation and an SOS
feature for emergency situations as well
if you're not sure which device is right
for you think about where you'll be
using the device and what features are
most important to you if you need a
lightweight compact option for
backpacking a bivvy stick might be the
better choice however if you want a more
robust device with additional features
like weather forecast two-way messaging
if you're going out camping or something
like that a satellite Communicator could
be the better option something that
brings me peace of mind is knowing that
even in a global disaster satellite
phones will keep me and my loved ones
always connected for limited time
satellite phone store has a special
promotional offer you go to sat123.com
Walsh you get a free baby stick or free
uh in marsat satellite phone included
with an applicable annual agreement so
head over to set
123.com that's sat123.com Walsh and get
your device today most people only think
about poor air quality when we have
fires like the ones that just happened
in Canada causing New York to be a
strange orange color that made the air
quality absolutely terrible but have you
stopped to think about the polluted air
in your day-to-day life you and your
family's health may be affected by the
air quality in your home allergens and
germs floating in the air you breathe
can make you sick but the good news is
there's technology out there that helps
you purify your living space easily and
affordably with Enviro cleanse you'll
never have to worry again Enviro cleanse
is an in-home air purifying unit
designed to destroy cold and flu viruses
allergy inflaming toxins mold and even
more Enviro cleanse promises far fewer
colds allergies and better sleep as well
their air purifiers come in all sizes
colors and prices to fit every budget
and they offer additional products like
Surface Cleaner and laundry detergent
Enviro cleanses the air purifier we use
in our home we've got several because of
allergies so we use Enviro cleanse for
that it's made it a lot better I love it
it gives me the peace of mind that I'm
breathing in healthier the last thing I
need with how often I'm traveling is to
get sick less than anyone in my family
needs is to get sick so Enviro cleanse
offers a simple solution for keeping me
healthy in a tough tip top shape breathe
in pure air and live a healthier life
visit ekpure.com and use code Walsh for
10 off your Enviro cleanse home air
purification and right now you get their
free air quality monitor plus fast free
shipping that's a 150 savings ekpure.com
that's ekpure.com promo code Welsh
so I go I think back to 2015 2016
and like anyone else in right wing media
at the time uh I didn't have a podcast
back then but I was I was writing a lot
and I was I was hammering on the point
that Hillary was a criminal and a crook
and the emails and all that okay like
some anybody else a conservative media a
lot of ink was spilled from me on that
subject lock her up I was chanting that
too and then Republicans take the White
House and the senate in the house and
they do nothing
they just do nothing they do absolutely
nothing
going into office lock her up lock her
up and then they're in office nothing no
attempts even to lock her up there's no
discussion
and I think most of the people that were
chanting it didn't believe it would even
happen didn't care if it did
if you'd asked most of them they said
well I'm not really going to put Hillary
Clinton in prison do you think we're
actually going to do that of course not
well for some of us know we actually
wanted you to do it it was not just
it's like we're not here talking about
how corrupt Hillary Clinton is for our
own health we're not saying it because
we enjoy talking about it
we want you to do something look at the
Democrats they are actually trying to
throw Trump in prison that is they are
really trying to do it
I don't like it I don't approve I think
it's an outrage
I think it's an actual attack on our
democratic system and all the Norms they
pretend to care so much about but uh but
they're following through they yelled
lock him up
and while I was in office you know
people on the left were saying when he
gets out of office we're gonna go after
this guy we're gonna take him down he's
going to pay for this they kept saying
that and uh and then and now they're
they're trying to do it
so they yell lock them up and then they
actually try to arrest not don't try
they yell lock them up and then they
actually proceed to arrest their
political enemies and try to throw them
in prison
whereas we yell lock them up and then do
nothing
it's all talk all slogeneering
so I want to see Republicans do
something we don't need to repeat over
and over again what we all know to be
true go do something uh the fact is that
you know Republicans aren't throwing
Republic corrupt Democrats in jail
anywhere even right now where they might
have the power to do so
that should have been the first response
to what they're doing to Trump
like there are Republican DA's out there
there are there are areas of the country
that are controlled by Republicans
why aren't they frog marching some
corrupt Democrats into prison to make an
example out of them why doesn't that
happen it's not happening anywhere
in fact it's the opposite corrupt
Democrats get get pardons okay the last
time Republicans were in charge corrupt
Democrats got pardons Kwame Kilpatrick
the absurdly corrupt uh Democrat former
mayor of Detroit okay the guy had been
convicted of perjury male fraud wire
fraud racketeering
it's like cartoonishly corrupt and a
Democrat
Trump commuted his sentence
so that's that's what we do with corrupt
Democrats we give them a helping hand
so
it doesn't excite me as much as it does
maybe some people we say oh we got him
dead the rights this time Biden look
this proves it yeah I mean it does
absolutely
doesn't excite me though because
um I have no faith at all the
Republicans will do a damn thing about
it once if if they ever have the power
to
hope I'm wrong
but action is what I'm interested in
it's not like I'm only applying that to
this topic
okay this is this is my approach to
anything
I care about action that's why I spent
the last two years of my life pushing
for laws and legislation Against Child
mutilation I'm not interested in just
talking about it
I want to see action I want to see
things done that's that's what I care
about
this is not just a topic for
conversation
I'm afraid for a lot of people on the
right especially a lot of people in the
right-wing media that's all it really is
just it's just stuff to talk about
really care about it
and so and and you know you'll know who
those people are
because if Republicans manage to take
the White House
in uh in 2024 and then are in a position
to actually hold Biden accountable
how many of the right wing commentators
and pundits right now who are going on
about Biden corruption how many of them
are going to push that Republican
president whoever it may be
how many are going to push him and say
okay follow through now do it
we're not going to take any no excuses
how many of them are going to say that
how many of them followed up once Trump
took office in 2016 and said what about
all the locking her up stuff what
happened with that
now the locker up is a is a is a mantra
it's a slogan precisely in the moments
when Republicans don't have the power to
do it
that has been the theme of the
Republicans forever
they're very excited about doing things
when they don't have the power to do it
and then when they have the power to do
it uh it's like it never happened we
forget about it
if you'd like to see what else I have to
say you can access my full show by going
to dailywire.com or by going to the Matt
Walsh Show Twitter page hope to see you
there Godspeed